une revendication des shebab le côté moi
bon non mais est ce que vous dites eric
ce que vous dites et riscle et c'est
exactement ça sur l'égalité à partir du
moment où deux femmes ont le droit
d'avoir un enfant avec la pma pour
toutes deux hommes auront aussi le droit
d'avoir un enfant ça change le meba
parvenir et demi c'est ce que vous
disiez comme s'il voulait vous disiez
par la gpa wii est donc le seul moyen
pour deux hommes d'avoir un enfant c'est
la gpr et c'est la question que vous
posez est ce que quand on va accepter la
pma est-ce que ça amène à la gpa
il semblerait que oui puisque dans un
principe d'égalité oui deux hommes le
seul moyen et non pas faire de peine
ça change un peu le débat non mais c'est
plus la six a changé c'est une hypothèse
c'est une épée de votre objection 22e
objection est un questionnement très
important et c'est vrai oui c'est pour
ça que je suis maintenant je suis là
parce que c'est plutôt d'absence dues et
du côté ballack en conclusion mais il
faudrait pas mais moi j'ai fait sur les
bourses qu'est-ce que tu permets arakel
que j'ai des doutes sont les sujets oui
mais j'ai des doutes sur tous les sujets
ce soir c'est un milieu où vous êtes a
également mitigé sur le j'ai peur
oui ah bon moi je suis face qu'on a on a
ben oui mais dans les faits c'est
également et c'est le seul pour
l'allemande a levé ce fasciné par ceux
qui sont favorables à la pma qui ne sont
pas favorables j'ai peur
voilà on est au coeur du sujet au coeur
du sujet et je tenais mais je ne vois ce
que j'ai à dire quelque chose qui
m'échappe
c'est l'ami 6 à 13 ans maintenant envie
d'avoir un enfant qui a envie de
procréer c'est pas la même chose que 2 2
mais klaus mais travailler et qu'ils
vont utiliser quand même mais qu'elle
revient avec des empires quelque chose
facile et vous allez leur ferme et que
je ne sois pas dans votre argumentaire
le pourquoi et le comment vous voulez
vous assimilez le pourquoi et le comment
le pourquoi dans la gpa dans la pma est
exactement le même
c'est le comment qui différé c'est donc
la technologie qui vous dérange dans
c'est la marchandisation
c'est pas du tout la même vision je suis
100% compose alors j'ai deux objections
majeures pour la m1 mais bon la culture
et la civilisation c'est de transformer
le corps qui est une matière en autre
chose qu'une simple matière brute mais
vous n'allez pas oublier quand même
que le corps de l'être humain et
biologiques cette biologie il faut la
penser
elle doit elle-même évoluer la manière
dont on perçoit son corps doit
historiquement évoluer et vous n'est pas
technologique vous perdez votre liberté
mais bien c'est la liberté de la
problème estimé comme bienvenue à
gattaca que au plus tard exactement plus
tard il faudra faire ça proprement
c'est-à-dire vérifié par l'état et sa
mutation ou le sol et roger léger les
faits par l'état emballé au parement
finances et encadrée parce que faire un
bébé sous la couette
c'est à la papa et bien moi je dis non
au contraire le corps humain et c'est à
dire ce qu'on en fait le gras demain ça
peut être juste juste en me demandent de
préciser la gpa c'est donc le recours à
une mère porteuse
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure mais à
l'étranger aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est
interdite en france
mais quand on a de l'argent on va à
l'étranger faire des gpa et quand
l'enfant revient sur le territoire
français heureusement on lui donne la
nationalité française moi je suis pas
content on même si on ne dit pas on l'a
toujours selon m mais avoir un enfant
c'est extraordinaire le cper l'espionné
qu'un conte peu un parcours du
combattant
il n'y a que des difficultés celui qui
tienne tu n'as pas à coucher tu as coûte
d'un bébé je pense que ça d'alors
laurent g
j'ai actuellement c'est vrai mais c'est
la dernière des neuf a encore dit ça
vient c'est bon ou non mais c'est pour
ça que je suis je suis contre la toux
121 bernard laporte absolument pas
couché et moi je pense qu'une femme
encore une fois toutes les femmes ont le
droit de vouloir accoucher d'un film
d'ailleurs avec jean sylvain trouillet
gpa je suis content et ménager l'intérêt
de la dernière étape avant l'utérus
artificiel
intro mû par un certain nombre de
chercheurs qui estiment que
l'inconvénient majeur dans le gpa c'est
la femme parce qu'elle peut changer
d'avis comme ça s'est passé je leur
accorde racontant mon livre une femme
qui avait qu'il voulait garder ses
triplés le son commanditaire a voulu la
faire avorter parce qu'il n'en voulait
qu'un et c est bien lui arracher ses
enfants et bien l'obstacle à une gpa qui
soit vraiment totalement maîtrisée par
les hommes de sexe masculin
eh bien c'est la femme et lui l'étape
suivante c'est le fantasme l'utérus
artificiel quinzaine avec un enfant dans
une machine bon moi j'ai lu non voilà
même je l'avais la technologie à savoir
non mais on a fait faire le tour
j'en ai pas de vous rappeler française
chez j'aimerais bien qu'elle est ce que
vous vous pensez qu'il y aura
automatiquement techniquement je le
ferais aura automatiquement la gpa sur
la base de l'égalité hommes femmes
puisqu'il y aura la pma pour toutes mais
ce sera la gpe j'espère que non mais
pourquoi à gaza bien sûr que l'argument
de s'adonner puisqu'il est d'ores et
déjà sur la table
j'espère qu'on saura faire la part des
choses entre d'une part une comme on l'a
dit une technique médicale qui ne fait
de mal à personne et qui contrairement à
ce que vous dites ne crée ne génère pas
une impossibilité naturel puisque ou
technique parce que c'est quand même
malgré tout quand même des sperme et
d'ovocytes on n'est pas bien que deux
oeuvres si oui donc pour l'intervention
de la médecine il faut l'intervention
n'est donc on n'est pas en train dans le
cadre est rentré dans l'impossible si je
me rappelle bien aurait désormais
mais mais effectivement moi je considère
que il faut être naïf pour penser que
dans une société de plusieurs milliards
d'habitants et d'habitants dont la
majorité est pauvrissime avec une idée
un accroissement des inégalités
absolument brutale et grotesque à
l'échelon de la planète
il faut être absolument naïf pour penser
que si on notera ficm en fait les femmes
louent leur utérus et le maçon de
subvenir alors alors alors propre besoin
pour vivre et pour s'alimenter je pense
qu'il faut être naïf pour pas penser que
ça n'a pas généré un marché mais moi
mais ça change compris mais tu es pays
mais pas possible étant donné que
technologiquement c'est possible donc ce
que fera l'amérique donnez moi un seul
exemple dans l'histoire de l'humanité de
quelque chose de technologiquement
possible qui n'a jamais baissé ça qui me
fait bander
vous confondez mais je la présente
circulaire encore des sons peuvent
adopter ou peuvent adopter les gens
d'abord s'est concerté des cendres est
ce que vous pensez vous aussi que la pma
valence est ce que la pma vase selon
vous menez automatiquement la gpa et
vous êtes contre la gpa chez moi je
trouve que ça trouble un peu le débat le
mot où le mot automatiquement
non le mot thématiquement nom qui est
des débats qui ont lieu je pense que la
résistance est quand même beaucoup plus
forte et qu'il ya des voix qui s'élève
dès maintenant je suis entièrement
d'accord avec elle j'espère que non mais
le mot automatiquement
non ce n'est pas un peu automatique eu
de fait et c'est pas parce qu'on est
passé ce que l'argument dire oui on est
passé de 2,2 du pacs au mariage cette
menace est ce pas là un tunnel sa
liberté égalité égalité hommes femmes
femmes hommes et c'est comme ça
malheureusement que ça basculera je
mangerai
10 à 10 les sens pour monsieur drevet
laissé entendre que l'on ne pouvait pas
arrêter la marche de la technique à moi
je dit vive la science mais ne
confondons pas le faisable et le bien et
le rôle d'un état le rôle d'une société
où le léguer à cesser de bloquer bloquer
les applications technologiques qui
détruirait l'humanité n'ait pas dit à
bien leurs élus je le dis pas ça la gpa
je dis pas ça je dis que dans l'histoire
n'y a jamais eu un seul cas de figure si
ou quelque chose de faisable n'ait pas
été fait dans l'exemple regarder la
légaliser les j'y viens dans mon enfant
bien justement là nombre et demi qu'elle
a eu lieu mais bien il ya eu une
désescalade heureusement et on s'est
battu pour qu'elles limiter le nombre
d'ogives afin que nous eh bien on va
faire pareil avec légèreté on va
l'encadrer y orienter escalade du
capitalisme et ont bien fait quoi sur
moi mais je dois dans l'engrenage ça se
fera de toute façon ça ce sera de toute
façon je suis pleine science ne pense
pas elle fait non